hey guys welcome to impaired I am JC
cariah's one of your co-hosts I am a
nefarious alcoholic sitting to my right
one of my best friends in the entire
world and probably the biggest pothead
I've ever met in my life and we're gonna
have some people on we're gonna play
some games we're gonna get [ __ ] up
welcome to impaired waited 165 pounds
this comedic dancing machine is given
Patrick Swayze a run for his money
he was on SNL but he got fired like
really quickly and will be appearing on
the NBC show champion's we bring you
this hilariously handsome man from
Harrington Park New Jersey John let's
speak yes I was standing at 6 foot 3
inches tall he hails from the City of
Angels
his tilt stages across the globe back
home he's been on who's coming to the
stage at the Mindy project he could be
seen in the upcoming HBO short film the
big chop let's welcome Shinobu
[Music]
hey guys welcome this is impaired I'm
Chris there's JCR get a weak chin do
naka Jon rudnitsky
Cheers
hell yeah yeah all right before we get
started I would like to take an extra
second congratulate our co-host JC cries
[Applause]
believe the Paul stuff I had to believe
in the end zero spreading Jim Beam yeah
v of celebrating Jim being a my look
ready Jim baby yeah okay guys real
quickly during the course of the show
there is a secret word none of us know
what it is so as we go through the whole
show if one of us says it what's this
time ago off o sound we've said the
secret word and we're gonna start
drinking or smoking we are using a
lovely bong same damn I thought I was a
secret man but yeah so you ready to
start the show mhm
all right boy all right so we jump into
some hometown harassment we're gonna
bring up some shitty things about where
you guys are from and then we're gonna
make fun of them let's talk about all
right all right Johnny boy my question
for you between 2010 and 2007 t6
residents if you could try a nice way in
back would you say what would you say we
listen I don't know you got to come up
with a better get her into the car how
to get them back like New Jersey uh
well first of all Eric depart New Jersey
is Pleasantville okay okay that's real
lovely
it really feels like a set red yeah Cory
Booker is is from there that was there
you go
Harrington Park is the ninth safest city
in New Jersey
yeah it's I just want to know why you're
saying such a little punk [ __ ] Jersey
how many cities are in Jersey too many
there's a locket I mean it's a tiny town
there's like sounds like it's like low
white collar Christ tonight oh yeah but
we thought like clothes exactly yeah you
could probably rent thin with your doors
on my federal care man yeah no I mean as
a kid I made my friends we just ran our
bikes around dude there was no no we got
in it
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh we're looking for it no there wasn't
that I'm gonna hear it go one of the
yeah one of the people who gave Philip
Seymour Hoffman heroin is so that's not
I know Cory Booker and you go into
Harrington the Cory Booker's a sign in
as you're leaving it's like by we also
some age did you know this about your
hometown but your hometown was the town
that gave birth to the perm one of the
worst hairstyles ever what do you have
to say for yourself wait Harrington Park
gave birth to the perm it was almost PT
i somebody's I swear to God like the
1920s were in the 1920s who let me see a
picture using a 1920 purse I didn't have
perm Jews ID
it was called a permanent back then you
have it I look this [ __ ] up
JC yeah when the press is our [ __ ]
research guy you know we're in a lot of
trouble here trying to sound consistency
in any of the backs that he's bringing
up I mean I certainly I never I've never
heard over greasy hair but I'm surprised
that you did your research on only the
way he defends himself egos it was on
the Wikipedia page so that's basically
what it is I mean I mean I didn't have
enough time to do it this week I was
busy being on TV
everybody keep it tight that's it for
Drive about JC do you want to do watch
Anna Duke to do it you're from Los
Angeles originally yeah yeah I'm from LA
that's a tough one to make fun we all
live here so I mean everybody's [ __ ]
on this city consistently sure I mean
obviously the thing that I hate more
than anything else is the 405 and did
you do that is that your fault did we
make rent so high you try to price this
out
I hate the 405 more than words can
describe it it isn't abyss used to be
worse before like really before paka car
we have a radio in the mid you so start
an argument in the car to go by you're
gonna need a book on tape when you're in
that [ __ ] traffic you can just read a
book
I live I have a theory that it's just
you know cuz actors actors don't really
act most of the time every year I
wouldn't come here don't come to Los
Angeles and if you're here already
get the [ __ ] Jesus Christ
alright what else we got in here Oh
Chris Mountain this I thought this was
[ __ ] the only city in America just
like you think the only city in America
demo Nazi camp in it
in the 1930s Murphy's ranch in Santa
Monica a Nazi camp summer 1930 man yeah
right basically it was right up until we
declared war on German
it was in the hills if there's one in
Santa Monica and a couple owned house in
the hills and they all sent a registered
it lasts up until we declare war in
Germany so like was that so thirty or
forty one you said it in the 30s again
there's Chris oh yeah their basic Nazi
sympathizers they had a ten thousand
gallon water tank house that can house a
ton of people and then a bunker that was
just recently destroyed Chris knows too
much about Nazis he watches too many
[ __ ] History Channel a white pose hi
people in the basement [ __ ] East Coast
right and so is this bad your basements
Jersey yeah we have basement there's no
way you never seen like all these
basement basement Chris is hurting
himself and then on the west coast I
noticed it's a lot of learning like nine
percent of black people we had a
headache from maybe fourth grade are no
why is that why do you think no one's
going in the Attic
yeah I feel like the majority of horror
movies begin in an attic or a basement I
never been in those are the scary places
of the house it read hide stuff writes
where secrets live it's also like the
Lighting's the line I get terrified no
windows usually in a basement or an
attic thanks for the Comedy Store scares
the [ __ ] out of me
bad juju man I don't think I knew they
had a basement yeah I do
in the upstairs in the roof entrance to
keep you if you bomb in the meanwhile of
it that's [ __ ] hilarious let's move
on the truth of toke man will play a
little truth of their essentially but
it's not there's no dare cuz we don't
want to get up so we're just getting
Darius right to Glee if we ask the
question you don't want to answer for
free alright I'll go first
uh but uh you know what John this one's
for you specifically
nom nom work ah did you hook up with any
I would be surprised no then anybody
knows that I was on the show all right I
got where's the intro is for both you
guys you ready oh this is for both you
guys out there have you ever had sex in
a public place and if so where are you
going first it's for both so yeah
masturbation count whoa
[Laughter]
where's the place on the 405 no I've
never had having sex in public place I
mean we were sitting in traffic I think
one time on a beach or something I
wasn't trying to get caught well that's
that's a crime I got a good one the the
parking garage in Burbank by flappers
there we go that's a good one
so it was because of us said what now it
was in the parking garage flappers
wasn't just like [ __ ] loose
I have a bigger car - it's a scion xb
what's up sighs that's a girl you
brought to the show she was a girl who
can't lose at the show it was something
that happened in the moment she rode
with me and such an actor this is so
said was that good sure I can't I
honestly think I bombed Wow
she pinned you how much it had to happen
right away save your career
yeah it really turned things around I
wanna quit I felt like I mean
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah but boy does it taste like there we
go it's smooth huh
I can't believe we didn't work it took
us the last time we take they tell us
the entire [ __ ] episode to hit it was
munchies really on a show called in the
pan no until until the food came out
until we did that segment with the food
guys answer the question though oh yeah
being talkin I've been a sober Bernard
yes how did you piss your pants summer I
really have to go you made a choice so
what happened I was pull out no I was in
the car and cuz I are you you know what
you see a total you have to go anymore
like we have to go already you know it
intensifies when we see like the safe
space yeah
but as a guy like to--let's count
parking lots trees anything dark oh yeah
and so put yourself you right and so
once you see that place you kind of lay
it loose and so I thought I saw a place
album kissing this alley real quick all
the sudden like these two girls turn the
corners like all right don't you paint I
had on thick sweats it was a nice pass
yeah I got sweats doesn't make it there
ballsy move to go
yeah well he just pissed yourself like I
couldn't do it I don't think I could
woke it up and feed myself that happened
it happen to be once I mean
unfortunately prior in the last like
couple years actually I was in a tan the
major sorrows birthright okay we're
doing it were you I don't know we're
near running all this no you're so being
a bear just dreaming about powerful
no it's not as easy as you think
adjusting just two tires off the
pitchers oh you had to override a lot of
commands
oh no no keys new commands we're tried
to make you pay that's what I'm saying
my name is it worse
I gave him how they look I got a hour
drive I'm not about to you know there
are stops you could go to help but see
like sometimes in LA like they won't
hire you so I was driving you gotta buy
a chatterbox at Covina
that's a 45-minute Drive this he's a
backward and I was like yo pull the car
over I have to go to the bathroom so bad
and I couldn't get into a gas station no
restaurants gonna let me use the
bathroom so I'm like [ __ ] it pull into
this like side street I was so
shit-faced I got out of the car and I
because I was trying to like make sure I
was hidden I pulled my dick out and I
actually was so close to the car that I
was peeing on the car and it was just
not your car correct no it was my
friend's car they were driving I was
peeing on their car but then it's just
splash back to all under my tan so the
entire time I was just peeing onto my
knee area yeah from the lino bounce off
it was great good times good times and
then I got a real good when I was in El
Paso I got the flu during the week of
road work and I sneezed in the hotel
while watching the horrible Kevin
Costner film draft day and I sharted my
pants so real wets got it that's a real
way
- diarrhea we love a fool - gave me the
shits man I was ruined regular flu is
gonna don't come a diarrhea yeah they do
hey yes they do oh no we're learning
my [ __ ] face in the shower that's
will poison no dog can someone give me a
panel I hopped and come on these are the
burning questions this will be perfect
on that you know half of it happy I
think I'm gonna blame some of it on
those on the day here you're surprised
about but the things that are normal to
you I'm not crazy
fantastic be careful well prevent
just bring you this back this bring back
any memories for anybody buying we do is
never done illegal everything passed the
statute of limitations you know so
everything happened 50 years ago
anything we talk about you know yeah I
[ __ ] my pants in 1961 that's it we got
next Chris we were doing true than toe
that was fun that was fun I share
stories that um we give there but you
guys what's going on with you guys yeah
see what's new with you what's going on
I'm a question for ya yeah I certainly
am and your dude does it frustrate you
that they're the stoners really don't
get [ __ ] for for their habit like you oh
yeah I think the drunks get a real bad
rap but I feel like it's only because
you can spiral out of control real hard
well yeah being a functional alcoholic
is are real like you got to balance a
lot right but like being a functional
pothead people just a [ __ ] idiot you
know but you're like not gonna ruin your
life like your wife's not gonna - it's
like a really if you can watch and never
sleeping on somebody else right exactly
pissing yourself and him and he does
that sober
[Applause]
[Laughter]
it's your jobs you got your lunch break
and you come back bombed your boss go
say something if you go to your car and
smoke on your lunch break there's a
weird stigma they're very similar so you
know put up against each other I felt
amazing I will say this I did during the
like the backstage area right they
[ __ ] brought me in to hair and makeup
and the lady put so much product in my
[ __ ] hair
she made it like a really tight little
afro but so she picked it all out and
then she sprayed it and I look like I
was wearing a [ __ ] helmet so I walked
into the green room where my buddies
were all hanging out and they the entire
room erupted in laughter yeah I was like
we need to fix this I'm about to go on
television right now so then it was me
and four people just pulling at my hair
trying to make it look kind of like what
my
it was a [ __ ] panic bomber man he's
like all the way I'm glad I was in the
audience for that yeah dude that
greenroom got real solemn we were like
oh no Jason was career out there because
if I would have walked out with the way
she did my hair that's there they didn't
ask her to touch it they did the makeup
and then the lady came home was like
what do you normally do with your hair
like I leave it crazy and she was like I
know exactly what to do with it and then
she just started going and I was too
polite right to say anything hey hey
[ __ ] you lady trying to ruin my goddamn
career code and Conan [ __ ] hair like
it was bad like she like made a hole she
made me look like a completely different
person well she put a ton of hairspray
in it and then she did a thing called
follicles okay
she likes sprayed it to make it a
different color in the front so I had to
go into the back like things I should
ask you I know this is why I need you to
be around that's what it is
I need someone to speak up for me also
to slap bad food out of my hand chin is
also really good at tailing your pitcher
so I'm making a I come to it did you
want ginger ale and coca-cola I buy your
show who just like brought blow just
like took it too far for Jacy - I'm
listening
who's your first celebrity crush cuz I
have mine it breaks my heart
okay first who is like yeah well you
went 13 14 I was earlier really earlier
oh yeah I was in fifth grade it's the
first woman I ever seen naked whoa it
wasn't like him personally yeah yeah
the warrior princess revealing a lot my
elementary school was right across the
street from a high school that I went to
mm-hmm and the high school kids for some
reason just oh like pages of like
Playboy of the game she was a national
what's the chick the war movie it was
Liv Tyler and Armageddon yeah I got that
for sure JC Lisa left eye Lopes you
probably read that in the same place you
read that
Erica Park invented the perm have
crushes on celebrities because they die
that's true Lisa left eye Lopes and alia
with a 200 Joule resin chills Miley Jill
was my first fun Tyler Crowe bro the
Army's he's saying look she's saying
like countrymen oh she was in that's her
that's her now though there were Myra
from family matters who's it don't want
to add a crusher article okay the paint
will feature not goofy movie
oh yes yes you want a bad man out of the
first cartoon yeah yeah tall shoulders a
bad cartoon can get it 100% all right
guys you know what we're gonna we're
gonna move on on to our our wasty
segment yeah you know we're going to
show you the this video we made hi mom
I'm drunk
so of course you talk hi hi know
basically what we do is we when you're
[ __ ] up the more you know nicely good
worth I'm just going I don't want to
talk over that
Thanks they're drunk - they're drunk -
so whenever you're [ __ ] up in your
home and you figure out what you want to
make we figured we'd make some beer
Jesse basically we got its money guys
welcome back to impair your host John
it's gonna do today we're talking about
we are cooking up something delicious
let's cut to it's basically it's Munchie
food it's what you find in your freezer
and what we do is we throw something
together some you might not think of you
know so this is a segment we call waste
e and check out the pizza Reno
[Music]
hey guys I hope you enjoyed the creation
of that and now to boom we got it right
here in front of us the pizza Reno kind
of taught it cut up into nice four
little pieces and then let's get after
it guys eat a diarrhea I might have to
watch draft right then I love it this is
I get to doodle-ooh doodle-ooh right
here I'm excited about the watch mmm
this is all right you got dry oh wow
this is really it's decadent its crunchy
sweet what is that is it pizza rolls a
bit of saffron
oh I knew you wanted it it's great cuz I
hate myself more with every bite oh my
god you like that so this is a so what
you've done is you've wood pizza oh good
it's pizza within pizza it's just a lot
with
pepper extra pepper against the pizza
inside a pizza - pretty much yeah
Mystics of it makes a lot of sense
there's no reason why I beat so and more
pizza wouldn't be good well I'm just
stopped
what are we doing that was one build
that peel back the layers not something
that's the mistake yeah I'm seeing
what's underneath it's a Rorschach test
oh my god okay yeah Wow oh yeah see you
guys are done all yours when you're when
you're when you're high you really do
like come up with chin your fringe ah
yes the first time iris I'm a guy ever
man yeah I was in college and my buddy
he smokes and he had hot wings and
peanut butter that's all he had in
fridge oh good time mr. oh my god it was
the most delicious thing I ever tasted
my life I put these hot wings in the
peanut butter it was so good you don't
I'll put peanuts and peanut butter I put
hot wings and peanut butter Wow
I can wait so it was funny some banana
though put the peanut butter in the
microwave I'm pretty sure I didn't I
think I just kind of went for it yeah it
wasn't a dozen to cover it though now
are you guys peanut butter in the fridge
people are peanut butter I'm a brother
in the cupboard cover man huh yeah I
grew up with the fridge really yeah but
I don't think butter does right butter
for sure mom hurt but she's she Nigerian
okay she put peanut butter in the fridge
yeah I only have one mom okay so yeah
that makes as of now I think it's a
cupboard thing it's a cupboard thing I
didn't realize until I was much much
much older right that you didn't need to
put I grew up with the peanut butter
fridge I'm going you know feel like
especially once I was like living on my
own at first I was in like college I
made the mistake of going like Oh peanut
butter and jelly go the same place I had
the jelly
yeah I made a sandwich put them both in
the recipe for canned tuna I can do it
dude okay not really a recipe for can
shut up I'll cut that pretty face are
you completely broken down
Chris is now threatening people this is
good no it's touching the rest my feet
Cerritos you understand me saw you but I
get to it I got after mine so yeah zero
is feeling a roll out he goes crispy it
was just soggy microwave ya know a me
back my dog all right let's open this up
just yeah thanks I don't know just
traveling it's the whole thing god
that's the skill man yeah I tried I buy
it like it specifically it's all like
and I try and match him all up like if I
make like automic tacos I put all the
taco items like together and it's like
separated mine or that way yeah that's
good yeah how did I bring you anything
you just don't bring you anything
anything and and and it's great because
it's triple the price that's great yeah
that's seven dollars for a Big Mac
brought to me Jesus
right now they were like pushing that
[ __ ] they were like ubereats now as
McDonald's they were like it's like on
[ __ ] ate goddamn billboards or you
know yeah ticker thingy Laker basketball
I love it are people just people are not
gonna drive to go anywhere anything
again exactly wall-e
no one sad about Toys R Us as close as
you hear about this can't like how
excited you were to the treat yeah I
really get till it was a treat yeah no
brothers Rafi why was your favorite run
to yellow someone yeah shut the [ __ ] you
did not like the red one a leader bro
there you go what that's I've never
heard any was the goofy one yeah dontel
is the smart one Reinhard was Obito
buddy sorry I was a really telling
anyone here all right is anyone else
I saw Donatello no way no [ __ ] way
right now
[ __ ] railroaded in here right us tell
us who your favorite ninja turtle ninja
turtle 89 thanks for a free can of tuna
oh [ __ ] straight in well there's been
great guys yeah we got one last segment
405 want to clean all this [ __ ] up and
then we're gonna get into it all right
guys
so our next you stole it like I called
you you're pissed pants all right why
you sweat so wet our next segment our
final segment is a meteoroid bartender
we're gonna get the name of a beverage
and we're gonna get a little hint about
what that beverages and then all four of
us are gonna try and make that cocktail
and then we're gonna find out what the
ingredients are see who got closest I'm
also gonna try every drink and then I'm
gonna pick a winner like my favorite of
the drinks even if it wasn't closed and
then today's cocktail is the bee's knees
it is a prohibition-era drink that was
invented as a way to hide the scent and
flavor of poor quality homemade spirits
poor shitty let's throw that time enough
you're doing Jim well nobody nobody's
you know that time rub we're gonna shoot
for it hey guys let's go let's make that
cocktail make that [ __ ] when you're done
with that gin over there bud I'll get
into that and then we explain what we
made correct yeah yeah Casey thanks bud
okay they go gin couple shots of gin
come on
because of bees you know I'm gonna zoom
honey put that in there after thank you
splash of cran this was gonna get you
[ __ ] up that's your party oh yeah
where we get times up shake it shake it
up shake that's okay we're all making a
mess this is what's fun I'm gonna pour
this bad boy in there that's pretty good
that's pretty damn good I like that
that's got a nice color to it I'm gonna
garnish it that's how I party right
let's actually set it aside here I
really just wanna hear good news oh
we're in which cup oh Jesus here we go
put that over here there's Christmas
take that all right let's get them off
in the shot right here line them up in
the order let's start with mr. Cohoes
over here Chris coke a little splash of
honey on that [ __ ] he's putting the
final touches okay
all my all rights a lot of my stuff is
color based okay for this direction so I
was thought like I said the bathtub gin
its approbation your drinks I wanted to
start there I put in pineapple because
bees are yellow I put lemon because bees
are yellow and want to be stings you a
little bit of cranberry oh it smells
fantastic and a look at money because
the bees it smells fantastic
I love that okay I like that
you took a sip of it how is it pretty
damn good
thank you that's a solid drink I would
drink this at a bar really I was really
good this I John your little explanation
of your beverage sir ah you know I don't
really have one much of one I just bee's
knees I definitely went with the honey I
thought I'd go with a brown okay
liquor Bushmills anyway yeah just you
know a lot of women I put a lot of lemon
I smell that it is masking the hell
which gave it was sweet and then just a
splash of ginger ale splash it feels
like a yeah like a classic I feel like
everybody got it absolute too much in
that it's like it's you take four or
five oh I'm also it's really strong it's
this you wait you went to town with the
booze I did an alcoholic say yes smell
it
wow you can't smell the alcohol made
Chris Moews the word [ __ ] that's a real
winner I can't go home okay
chili do alright I see that you have
honey at the top
all right
extra extra
okay I see how much you got boy oh boy
with a pineapple can I'm the only one
who garnished it a little bit lemon I
will put that in gin pineapple juice
honey as well and then a splash of
cranberry and then the lemon on top
it looks great that can make three more
fantastic would anyone else like to try
it yeah
it's very good okay let's here let's you
know let's find out what the actual
cocktail was made up Joe in an actual
bee's knees is just gin honey and lemon
that's what I told you it was closest oh
I missed a lemon would you do actually I
had a pineapple and I did pineapple and
cranberry yeah I would say we made this
almost positive it's whiskey and a ton
of lemon and if we're going by that
Johnson Keys let's give it up for our
guest hey guys thanks so much
this last wagon shop to a bee's knees Oh
Toby join us for another episode of
impaired neugast every week and people
are gonna keep getting [ __ ] up here I
cannot believe you were drinking the
straight Bushmills everybody gets over
to and from this show know that he's
driving the uber
[Applause]
[Music]